Oh, no.
- Hey Toby! It looks like you have a problem.
- I sure do, Lena.
- Oh, no.
- I'm just too tired to do *this*!
- That is a problem. But I think I've got just what you need!
It's something I like to call.....
- Oh yeah, that sounds great, but what does it look like?
(chuckling)
- Well, take a look, silly!
(more chuckling)
- Whoa! Now that's a design! But Lena, my brain is bad, I can only remember things that have a catchy tagline!
(even more chuckling)
- Then take a gander, here!
(wheeze)
-Oh, boy! That'll be stuck in my head for days!
(dangerous chuckling)
(dying)
- That's the idea, and that's how it's done, everybody!
(audience applaud)
(dying in the background)
(more dying)
Let the master show you how it's done. What's up, Toby? Seems like you have a problem.
- You bet I do, Lena!
I'm just too tired to do *this*!
(dying hacks)
That's a doozy! Well, have I got just the thing for you!
(dying wheeze)
It's simply called....
- My prayers have been answered!
(dangerous immature giggling)
But, whats it look like?
- Glad you asked. Take a look at this!
(dangerous immature giggling)
(sounds of a dying man)
- Piccaso couldn't have drawn this better, himself!
- This looks great, Lena, but without a tagline, I'm afraid I just won't remeber it.
(inhale)
(sounds of a dying man)
- This looks great, Lena, but without a tagline, I'm afraid I just won't remeber it.
(sounds of a dying man and chuckling)
- Well, you're in luck!
- Boy, that'll be stuck  in my head for DAYS!
(sounds of a dying man and chuckling)
- It sure will!
- And, scene!
(sounds of a dying man and chuckling)
(audience applauds)